hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game app from the Shah
bundesligan uh this is the second round
between paveliyanov and vasley when
chukso an all-out Ukrainian match and uh
sorry about no videos yesterday and
maybe even the day before that I my
daughter caught something in the
kindergarten and then I caught it as
well and it just completely mowed me
down uh so I wasn't really able to to do
any videos and I wasn't even paying
attention to what was happening in the
Chess World so I was very very happy
when I saw this game because now that
I'm all better we can enjoy some really
really good chess so uh let's dive
straight into it uh it's a wonderful
game wonderful attack very short game so
uh you know don't don't blink otherwise
you'll you will miss something so Pavel
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to D4 now the two of them have met
uh many times throughout their lives and
they've played some 12 games all
together in classical chess and out of
those 12 games a lot of only a 1-1 game
in the 2014 Ukrainian Championship all
the others were either drawn or won by
vassal so this is uh
a great game especially if you have that
in mind sorry Meadow wants to come in
again
I mean I I always ask him does he wants
to does he want to come in but uh you
know he's just weird like that but okay
D4 by Pablo and vasel replies with Pawn
to D5 we have Pawn to C4 C6 the slav
defense is on the board Knight to F3 we
have Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E3 the
quiet variation of the slab but not as
quiet as you'll see Bishop to F5 we have
knighted the C3 and now Pawn to E6
closing up the the structure now that
you've developed your light Square
version and of course uh Pavel goes
after at night stage five goes after the
bishop Bishop G6 and now Bishop to E2
continuing development Knight b37 with
castles and only now D captures and C4
Bishop captures you know there are ways
you could continue this game you could
go after the bishop you could play Queen
to C7 but it was still yeah it just goes
Bishop to H5 he says I'm not uh
obligated the allow you Knight captures
the bishop and you know just all allow
you to have the bishop repair so why not
attack your queen and now it's your move
do you bring the Knight back that kind
of loses you the tempo or do you want to
play version back to E2 so Paul goes
Bishop back to E2 and now Russell
happily trades The Bishop's captors
captures and now point the C5 striking
against White Center
and all is well here so Rook to D1 makes
sense as the black king is uh Queen is
still on the eighth C captress on D4 e
captures and not Knight the B6 with full
control over that D5 square and now
Knight the F5 so is vassal's King in the
center of the board a bit too long uh
can and can can he get out of this well
the way is the Knight actually
threatening anything the problem is you
can't really develop your Bishop once
you move the bishop the G7 Pawn will
hang so how do you play this well best
is to play Queen to D7 and then just
hope for the best but in the game Knight
F the D5 was played which is also
somewhat playable and also it is not as
of move 14 that we have a completely new
game and now of course Pavel declines
the trade Knight the E4 still leaving
the Knight hanging uh because uh well if
you capture then it's just a nice
meeting one Knight to F6 check it's a
double check so also uh it's uh it's
Checkmate the king cannot go to D7 light
covers that square so that would be it
so instead after Knight the E4 vessel
says all right that's uh will very
unfortunate for me I'm just gonna play
H6 he's gonna
grab control over the G5 square and now
uh uh Paul just uh has to figure out a
way of how to how to mount this attack
so he starts with Pawn to A4 and this is
a critical idea in some of the lines
that we will discuss as it takes away
the A4 Square for the Knight if you
don't know about this position and if
you've just uh you know if you just see
it for the first time chances are you
will not find A4 even though these are
very very strong or older generation
Grand Masters they would find ideas like
this so upon the A6 and now Knight the
C5 uh going after the B7 Pawn so what do
you do here if you capture the Knight
Bishop captures and C5 just D captures
and C5 and notice now that the Knight
really doesn't have any good squares
plus you've taken away the A4 Square for
the Knight you have to go C8 or D7 if
Knight's the D7 then you can just play
root captures on D5 the queen no longer
the the defends on D5 so D6 Pawn is
pinned and if you're going night the C8
World dangerous Knight captures and
Jesus 7 check completely
uh destroys Black's position so instead
after Knight the C5 Queen to F6 vasel
goes for the counter attack he he gives
up the B7 pawn and now uh just Knight
the G3 and here again how do you
continue the game it's a it's a very
very tricky position I will just show
you a couple of really really
interesting ideas for example if you
play Bishop to A7 it's a move that you
definitely want to play you want a
castle and you know just run away to
safety now Knight H5 can be a bit
annoying and um uh your queen is hanging
and if Queen to G6 not just Rook A3 and
again you cannot castle if you Castle
now then just Rook G3 and black resigns
the G7 Pawn will hang uh and that's it
so it's uh it's very problematic to get
out of this position especially if you
play something like Bishop t7 which is a
move you want to play another idea is
Queen to G6 now this is a little bit
better than Bishop t7 because the
standard Rook A3 maneuver no longer
works now you don't really care there's
an I10 G3 you can simply develop the
bishop that's it Bishop D6 and you will
Castle however white of course is not
obligated to play Rook day three white
can play something like Knight captures
and B7 which is why the Knight came to
C5 and you're just gonna claim that you
are now better if Bishop t7 Knight comes
back to C5 okay Rook A7 and now you hope
to hold this you hope the castle and you
hope that white doesn't have enough
already to just win the game but okay
after Knight the G3 vasel plays Rook to
B8 he says I'm not uh falling for
anything I'm just gonna defend my B7
pawn and you know you prove that your
your whatever you are doing is actually
something so okay Rook the A3 that was
the idea one of the ideas behind the A4
the other one was just to take away the
A4 Square from the Black Knight and now
the Rook can come to F3 to G3 or
depending on what black plays the any of
the squares Knight the D7 now putting
pressure on the Knight here and C5 and
now comes Knight to H5 and here we have
a beautiful Beauty beautiful position
where Russell has to make a decision
does he want to go back and if he wants
if he goes back it's not going to be
easy for him for example Queen to E7
then comes Rook to F3 and there's not
all that much for you to play for for
example if Knight captures on c5d
captures you're gonna play Rook to d8
and you will you will fight valiantly to
hold this but for example Rook after D3
and after Queen captures on C5 now Queen
to G4 and there's so much pressure on
Black's position uh you can't move the
Knight the the rook and d8 is undefended
there's just
um not a lot you can do the G7 Pawn is
hanging now you can attack it you can
play something like Rook to H7 to defend
it and then I don't know if maybe some
like Queen E4 the shouldn't work it's
sort of a repetition of moves Queen hero
goes back uh it would be a position
where of course white should win whether
he would win probably uh probably yes in
um uh you know in in this sort of a
matchup but Russell made things even
more interesting he played Queen to F5
and now his idea is well of course if
Rook to F3 that blocks the Queen's
defense of the Knight so I'm just gonna
capture the Knight so what else can
white play well there is a winning idea
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this move while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not paying
attention to what I was saying and only
uh listening to the position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to F3 regardless yes
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are truly a spectacular player
Rook the B3 if you asked the engine will
also be winning just going after the B7
Pawn but we are not trying to bore our
opponent to death we want to completely
crush him so this is what Pavel played
Rook to F3 goes after the queen and
sacrifices the Knight and this is where
it gets incredibly interesting it's it's
impossible to decline the the the night
sacrifice you have to accept it it seems
like you could go maybe to G4 or G6 but
Queen G4 uh just loses terribly tonight
captures on D7 now black lost the piece
you cannot recapture if you recapture
just real characters on F7 with check
hangs the queen and if Queen to G6 which
is a bit more resilient not by much just
Knight captures on D7 now King captures
no kdf7 Pawn is now defended but now
Knight to F4 attacks the queen and the
Knight here now look at this Knight
captures Bishop captures attacks the
rook and B8 and again if you give it up
you're just gonna lose by material so
Rook the C8 and now D5 and now look at
this once the position opens up there is
no saving this position uh from from all
of White's pieces they are just all
coming down on the black king uh of
course you you you're gonna play some
like E5 you don't want to open up the uh
you know files for for the white looking
queen as you are a sane person uh but
even this will not help you for example
Bishop captures now Bishop D6 you can
play this let's say bash of characters
King captures and now Queen E3 with all
sorts of nasty threads just going for
Queen to B6 let's say King D7 even D6
now even that's possible like there
there's absolutely no playing this if
some like Rook Rook hd8 you can even
play Queen to B3 after B7 and now you're
attacking F7 as well black just resigns
here it's actually forced mate in some
10 moves so you will not be able to
survive this so this is the most uh
unpleasant sacrifice you can face in a
chess game the one that you don't want
to accept but you absolutely must accept
so here Queen captures on H5 was played
by Russell but now comes the actual
trick in the position and that is Knight
captures on E6 beautiful double Knight
sacrifice but now the other Knight
cannot be accepted even though if you
ask the engine it is the best move uh
you you should accept it and give up
your queen like this through a capture
through captors or King captures and
queen captures on H5 with the check uh
even better would be to capture with the
king so this doesn't come with the check
and okay you have a bishop rook and
queen against two Rooks Knight and
Knight so it would be uh basically you
would have
um you you wouldn't have much it's a
knight and Rook for a queen and the
white is winning but maybe maybe you can
fight in the game night the E7 was
played the vasel was trying to hold on
to everything but now just Rook to E1
and it was in this position unmoved 23
that the Vaseline manchuk resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here
so truly a remarkable game uh there's no
more we can even try black is completely
tied down that's why I use this position
as the as the thumbnail I mean it's uh
not a position you see every day
definitely not something you would
expect in a game in between modern Grand
Masters you know when when we have first
20 moves of unknown Theory okay here
there was also a lot of theory first 14
moves were known Theory but it was a
sort of a sideline of a sideline and
then you know something a very very
interesting happened uh but yeah yeah
here of course this is still impossible
root capture still hangs the queen and
if you try anything else uh you could
play Queen G6 okay you move the queen
away from H5 uh now you just start
gobble uh gobbling up pieces Knight
captures on f8 now threatens Queen
capture Sun E7 Checkmate so you have to
capture with the King not Queen capture
Sun E7 King to G8 now Queen captures on
D7 and by doing nothing you've uh I mean
you're up a full Bishop so of course
this is complete winning and even to
make matters worse you can just force an
end game so there's nothing to even try
here for black and other than the this
queen to G6 idea there's really nothing
else to try like uh Last Resort would be
if captors and E6 but if you already
didn't want to play this on the previous
moon now it would be just silly to play
it I mean it would be uh you I mean if a
grand master did not play it the first
time you will not play it the second
time that's that's even worse than
making a bad move
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a true brilliancy by
paveliano against such a such a
brilliant player uh you know opposite
himself like like vastly even Chuck I
mean absolutely incredible I I usually
follow as vasel you know is one of my
favorite players so I often uh follow
what he does and what he plays so I was
very happy to see that he played a a
brilliancy in 23 moves even though he
was on the receiving end of the
brilliancy but still yeah you know good
stuff
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
listerpan Joshua Baker Derek Alex
Williams Stephen Pryor and uh
subramanian for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day